notre bon gère filoche membres de la
gauche démocratique et sociale et jean
paul stahl infectiologues au chu de
grenoble
un bon soir à messi au fc lettres avec
nous en direct sur arte france on vient
d'entendre le maire de marseille 4-1
commentaires là-dessus jean paul stahl
est ce qu'à votre avis ce variant et il
circule activement sur le territoire
hoyé circulent dans quelles proportions
je ne peux pas vous le dire mais il ya
que je voudrais d'abord rectifier une
heure à meaux qui a été prononcé et
qu'il faut ce virus mutant n'est pas
plus virulent c'est à dire que quand ils
infectent quelqu'un et ne le rend pas
plus malade et cette personne n'a pas
plus de risques qu'une autre de faire un
séjour en réanimation par exemple donc
il faut remettre les choses à leur place
mais il est plus contagieux ça c'est
vrai et donc à ceux à ce titre là il est
plus dangereux puisqu'il peut provoquer
plus d'infections est donc évidemment
plus de personnes atteintes d'une forme
grave et il n'est pas plus virulent
alors après est-ce qu'il circule ben oui
forcément y circulent en france sans
doute à bas bruit dans une proportion
que pour l'instant on ne peut pas
chiffrer mais ce variant circule ce
qu'il ne change pas grand chose à vrai
dire parce que effectivement on peut
être plus jacques est d'accord mais en
termes pratiques
qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire derrière va
appliquer les mesures barrières
il n'y a que ça et dans les endroits où
il y a une une incidence élevée de la
circulation virale et vient ma foi c'est
le couvre-feu et à l'extrême ça sera un
grand film ans alors justement se
couvrent cela huit départements
supplémentaires
ce soir à partir de 18h donc pratiquer
ce couvre-feu avancé gérard filoche
pourtant les élus locaux
voilà exprime quand même un certain
mécontentement pour pour quelles raisons
vous je la comprends il ya beaucoup de
gêne à cause de toutes les mesures de
précaution de prévention qui sont prises
mais moi j'écoute monsieur quête
infectiologues et je pense aussi que le
maire de marseille et lui parle
printemps marseillais réagit très bien
faut prendre les mesures de prévention
qui sont nécessaires au fur et à mesure
la prévention dans le pays elle est
totalement insuffisant de façon générale
un de ces 5 4% des dépenses de santé et
la vaccination et le même jusqu'à
présent il ya eu peu de moyens engagés
et un retard visiblement le gouvernement
actuel on est toujours en retard d'une
plage quand il n'y avait pas de soi il
n'y avait pas de poussan il n'est pas
qu'elle n'y avait pas de test et pas de
respirateur il n'y avait pas de blouse
n'y avait pas dedans il n'y avait pas de
lune et y avait pas de soignants et il
n'y avait pas assez de lits dans les
hôpitaux de façon générale et maintenant
il n'y a pas assez de vaccins où ça ne
va pas assez pour revenir à ses
prouesses qu'il est utile
est-ce qu'il est utile ce couvre-feu
avancé à 18 heures je peux pas juger moi
je je regarde les décisions qui sont qui
sont prises 6 et 18 heures et 18 heures
19 heures peut-être faut-il comme ça a
été dit précédemment un confinement
général à nouveau nous allons nous
allons voir moi je ne suis pas en mesure
de décider nous disposons pas de toutes
les informations
en termes de développement du virus sur
le territoire a ce virus mutant et donc
je suis très prudent j'écoutais je suis
respectueux je dis aux gens il faut
écouter la prévention c'est très
important
le principe de précaution et l'emporter
savez j'ai été longtemps inspecteurs du
travail et on disait aux gens porter des
chaussures de sécurité tiraient pas des
accidents pour tous les gens mais on est
obligé tous les gens à porter les
chaussures de sécurité
c'était pareil pour les casques il n'y
avait pas forcément des dangers pour
tout le monde mais fallait des casques
dans des chantiers
et bien tout le monde aujourd'hui est un
peu comme dans un chantier faut porter
des chaussures de sécurité aux portes et
des casses au sens où on fait des gestes
barrières et respectent les mesures de
confinement qui sont pris j'en fais
partie
les réfractaires ça c'est personnel
qu'au niveau de confinement ont
peut-être pas été suffisant donc
derrière nous jean paul stahl parmi les
réfractaires à sa couvre-feu avancé il
ya ceux qui argumentent en disant que à
18h finalement la population à risque
elles sont déjà chez elle selon vous est
ce que cette mesure elle peut s'avérer
efficace un problème c'est pas l'épopée
est les personnes à risque le problème
c'est la circulation du virus y compris
chez ceux qui ne sont pas à risque je
dirais même surtout chez ceux qui ne
sont pas un risque donc non c'est bien
ça c'est un argument qui n'est pas
valable
là le virus qui circule chez les
personnes à faible risque et qui
contamine les personnes à risque qui a
ce moment la foi et les formes graves
on est bien d'accord mais je ne savais
ce semi réussite tombe pas du ciel il
c'est un individu porteur du virus qui
le transmet à un individu récepteur bon
à partir de là toutes les mesures
quelles qu'elles soient toutes les
mesures qui tendent à diminuer ce
contact entre le porter et le récepteur
est une bonne joueuse lieu alors après
le confinement à 20 heures d'accord il a
marché
il a montré qu'il était efficace parce
qu'on a vus avant le le confinement le
couvre feu
pardon je me suis relax cus mais le
couvre-feu marche
londres 1 a vu les résultats de juste au
début du confinement il n'était pas
assez important ses résultats d'où le
confinement qui a suivi mais ça marche
bien et fait maintenant vous dire si le
18 heures c'est mieux que le batteur ou
16h mieux que 18 heures tout ce qui
empêche l'interaction entre individus et
est une bonne chose on dire sur votre
l'abscisse on va repos bien sûr on va
rebondir justement jean paul stahl sur
votre lapsus le confinement est ce qu on
peut hésiter gérard filoche à votre avis
à un troisième confinement parce que
c'est ce que souhaite justement éviter
lé les autorités pour pouvoir concilier
la vie économique et des impératifs
sanitaires et je comprends qu'il faille
donner la priorité à la santé n'ont pas
si vous me permettez au fric
1 c'est tant pis y ait des choses qui
marche pas tant pis s'il ya des
productions qui ne se font pas c'est la
santé en priorité
donc le gouvernement quand il prend des
mesures de santé je le soutiens quand il
dit dans un an ça coûte trop cher je le
soutiens plus quand monsieur le maire
donne 100 milliards ou en entreprise au
lieu de donner aux pauvres on a huit
millions de personnes aujourd'hui qu'on
des problèmes alimentaires en france on
a 10 millions de pauvres
évidemment tout ça a un coût eh ben
c'est coûte que coûte il faut donner la
priorité à la santé
et ça veut dire aussi des choses
précises parce que on est en situation
de danger
eh bien il faut aider les soulignant je
plaide à nouveau pour les salaires des
soignants 300 euros pour tous je plaide
à nouveau pour qu'il y ait des ailes à
tous ceux qui en bas souffrent des
conséquences du confinement
parce qu'on peut pas dire aux gens
protégez-vous ce qui est rien et en même
temps ne pas leur donner de quoi manger
puisque ils vont plus avoir d'indemnités
de travail il faut coller les jeunes
disposent de l'équivalent d'un rsa parce
que si où ils peuvent pas de s'en sortir
il faut que les gens qui sont pauvres et
dz suffisante et que celle ci ne soit
pas réservée au cac 40
monsieur le maire et monsieur macron
donne l'essentiel de l'argent qu'ils
dépensent aujourd'hui au cac 40
c'est une anomalie total faut le donner
aux gens qui souffrent des conséquences
du confinement et des exigences de
protection de santé et je pense que tout
ça se
ce lien de la même façon que la
reconnaissance du coup vite comme
maladie professionnelle parce que rial
et policiers il ya les soignants mais il
ya plein de gens qui continuent de
travailler malgré ce que nous sommes en
train de dire
et ils n'ont pas la reconnaissance du
cockpit comme maladie professionnelle
forêt se soit fait de façon absolument
systématique et je pense que c'est une
vision là sont aussi importante pour le
moral des gens pour ceux qui travaillent
c'est aussi important pour subir les
conséquences du confinement c'est
désagréable confinement c'est
désagréable et gestes barrière c'est
désagréable et couvre feu mais il faut
quand même qu'on pense et ça en vain de
redistribution des richesses que nous
avons en direction de ceux qui en ont
besoin
j'ai un très grand reproche à monsieur
macron à monsieur le maire c'est
d'utiliser ils ont trouvé de l'argent
magique alors qu'ils aient qu'il n'avait
pas fait il utilise pas dans la bonne
direction
il ne donnera aux riches sur le dernier
rempart à tous ceux qui sont pauvres qui
souffrent c'est vrai qu'on voit bien
gentil mais ça les conséquences des
restrictions sanitaires notamment
capacités mais on peut citer les les
commerçants les cafetiers et les
restaurateurs
tous les professionnels aussi des
secteurs de la culture l'idc on voit
bien pour le gouvernement c'est
d'éditeurs confinement c'est le cas en
ce moment par exemple au royaume uni on
marque on finit surtout avec la
circulation du nouveau variant comment
on peut hésiter un jean paul stahl à un
troisième confinement en france on a en
arrêtant de penser que c'est les autres
qui doivent faire les efforts c'est à
dire que chacun d'entre nous est
responsable c'est pas le gouvernement
qui nous contamine c'est pas une
administration sadique qui nous
contamine c'est chacun d'entre nous qui
contamine d'autres voisins quand on est
porteur donc à partir de là plutôt que
de vitupérer contre telle ou telle
mesure
je pense qu'il ya un discours de
responsabilité à tenir en disant vous
êtes chacun d'entre vous responsables de
la contamination d'autres voisins donc
appliquer les mesures barrières
c'est extrêmement simple c'est à cette
condition là qu'on arrivera à éviter un
troisième grand film
si on ne l'observé pas si nos
concitoyens ne l'observent pas et on a
vu qu'il avait quand même une forte
réticence à l'observer à l'occasion des
fêtes de fin d'année et bien ma foi
même si cette réticence est
compréhensible elle n'est pas
responsable et en tout cas et les
responsables de quelque chose c'est du
troisième confinement s'il doit avoir
lieu on voit ce qui se passe ailleurs
chez nos voisins européens par exemple
en allemagne on l'a dit tout à l'heure à
l'angola merkel qui alerte face au pire
en attendant les effets de la
vaccination justement sur le front de la
campagne de vaccination libérant a
annoncé que ce week-end on devrait
passer la barre des 100000 vaccinées en
france à quoi s'attendre dans les
prochaines semaines à gérard filoche
j'espère que ce sera pas 100 milles mais
des millions j'espère qu'il va enfin un
effort
au début ma chrome dadis et la guerre
lui fait pas beaucoup d'efforts de
guerre pour la vaccination
parce que s'il y avait un effort de
guerre pour la vaccination serait déjà
plus avancées et donc je pète plutôt
dans ce sens là je plaide en fait
pourquoi ce que disait monsieur avant
moi c'est il faut faire c'est très faut
responsabiliser
mais en même temps faut permettre une
acceptabilité la responsabilisation
certain que ce soit pas des sacrifices
trop dur que ça ne soit pas
insupportable du point de vue de ceux
qui n'ont pas les moyens et c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut se tourner parce
que c'est lié de convaincre les gens
d'accepter des mesures de protection et
de prévention si en même temps on leur
donne les moyens de le faire alors pour
l'instant je partage avec vous l'idée
qu'il faut exiger au sens
responsabiliser
mais je dis que l'autre côté y'a pas la
contrepartie les contreparties
financières tous les moyens toutes les
aides
ils vont en haut au gros et non pas en
bas à ceux qui sont les plus frappés les
plus atteints par le virus ce sont les
ceux qui sont les plus démunis qui sont
les plus atteints aujourd'hui saison
casse à ça qu'il faut adapter la
politique
après je me garderai bien je suis pas
infectiologues le suivre
je ne suis pas compétent pour dire
cesser 18h ou 19h jeu
des fonds que l'idée générale priorité à
la prévention et priorité à la
précaution et priorité allait des sceaux
qui en souffre et j'entends cela nous
est confiant sur le front de la
vaccination en france pour les
prochaines semaines de vaccination il
aura lieu le le problème tout le monde
est maintenant les lacs salés dax après
avoir dit le daxas je veux pas donc là
il ya déjà une forme de schizophrénie
mais bon peu importe tant mieux si on
bascule du côté de la réclamation du
vaccin ça c'est une chose très positive
par contre le vaccin alors ne sort pas
comme ça d'un claquement de doigts d'une
usine
lusine il faut la construire il faut la
produit il faut produire les vaccins en
quantité etc
vous imaginez qu'il y avait des besoins
actuellement dans le monde entier le
plusieurs milliards de doses
et ça il faut quand même les produits
donc effectivement la france a une une
quote-part dans un claquement de
européenne mais c'est pas non plus des
quantités illimitées qui sont déversés
en france donc on est bien obligé
d'adopter une stratégie de priorisation
si on veut protéger les personnes pour
qui c'est vraiment utile dans un
contexte où il y à une relative rareté
du raft et du vaccin alors après au fil
du temps effectivement les quantités
vont augmenter ça c'est absolument
certain
d'autant plus que d'autres vaccins
sommes maintenant sur le point de sur le
point d'arriver il ya le vaccin moderna
la sellette cette semaine et puis albax
un astra qui lui qui a des conditions
logistiques beaucoup plus simple qui va
arriver un tout petit peu décalé et qui
permettra d'augmenter la masse des
personnes que l'on pourra vacciner mais
il y a on peut pas s'attendre à vacciner
dix ans personne comme ça alors on a 500
milles 12 cm absolument un faisable donc
je laisse bien d'autres pays qui ont eu
cette stratégie d'utiliser très
rapidement tous les stocks disponibles
et qui maintenant se retrouve un petit
plus que david
en attendant ce qu'elle est née des
fournitures suivante
donc ils ont donné l'impression d'avoir
démarré la course très très fort mais
ils sont dans des phases de
ralentissement alors que nous on a
choisi une stratégie je dis pas qu'elle
est la meilleure
je m'avancerai pas je m'avancerai pas là
dessus et on dira qu'elle est la
meilleure quand tout sera fini
la maintenance est beaucoup trop
prématuré pour porter un jugement
simplement je prends une explication sur
le fait de ce déploiement qui semble
mettre du temps mais en tenant compte de
la pesanteur administrative française
que tout le monde connaît
c'est une stratégie qui a été définie
par des vrais spécialistes de la
vaccinologie est chaud très sincèrement
je la soutiens merci beaucoup à vous
jean paul stahl infectiologue au chu de
grenoble merci également à vous gérard
filoche nombre de la gauche démocratique
et sociale